supongamos que tenemos la función
mayúscula de x igual a la integral de
vía x de con tangente cuadrada de tdt y
que queremos derivar las queremos
encontrar f prima de x o bien la
derivada con respecto a x de esta
expresión de acá déjame la copio es la
integral de ti a x dejo tangente
cuadrada o tangente cuadrada de t de t
esto básicamente es una aplicación
directa del teorema fundamental del
cálculo verdad ya tenemos que derivar
una integral de vía x donde x es la
variable de la función entonces aquí
dentro tenemos una ft esto simplemente
es igual a fx y f es como tangente
cuadrada de entonces nos quedaría con
tangente cuadrada de x salen estos
problemas los vas a ver muy seguido en
competencias de cálculo y en exámenes
difíciles yo no puede decir tanto se lo
tengo que hacer esta integral y van a
salir muchas cositas y luego tengo que
derivar pero no te preocupes o sea
realmente basta utilizar el teorema
fundamental y las cuentitas salen muy
limpias
ahora imagínate que en vez de que nos
pidan derivar esta integral nos piden
derivar con respecto a x derivar con
respecto a x la integral la integral de
otra vez con tangente cuadrada de t o
tangente cuadrada de t
dt pero ahora no va de pie x si no va de
pi de vía x cuadrada lo voy a poner con
rosa para que quede muy claro que
estamos haciendo vale entonces que estoy
acá pues ve yo digo que esto es la
derivada la derivada con respecto a x
acá es básicamente esto pero cambiando
la x por equis cuadrada entonces aquí
nos quedaría la derivada con respecto a
x de f y aquí adentro va x cuadradas y
mira f mayúscula de x cuadrada
simplemente es poner aquí en vez de xx
cuadrada o sea poner aquí x cuadrada y
eso es justo lo que queremos y esto de
acá ya no sabemos derivar porque es una
composición de funciones verdad así que
aquí tenemos que utilizar la regla de la
cadena hay que hacer él
el de afuera derivado evaluado en lo de
adentro multiplicado por la derivada de
lo de adentro entonces déjame ponerlo
nos quedaría la derivada de f con
respecto a x evaluada en lo de adentro
que es x cuadrada x cuadrada y luego
tendríamos que multiplicar por la
derivada de lo de adentro por la
derivada con respecto a x de x cuadrada
y estoy acá ya lo podemos hacer deja lo
hago por acá abajo porque porque la
derivada de f mayúscula con respecto a x
pues ya le encontramos este f prima de x
que es tangente cuadrada de x pero ahora
la queremos evaluar no en x sino en x
cuadrada entonces estoy acá nos quedaría
con tangente o tangente cuadrada de x
cuadrada de x cuadrada fija me lo pongo
con el color rosa de x cuadrada x
cuadrada x la derivada con respecto a x
de x cuadrada que simplemente 2
muy bien entonces ya nada más déjame
reorganizar estoy acá para que quede un
poco más bonito y de esta forma la
derivada de esta expresión es 2x x con
tangente cuadrada de x cuadrada y aquí
tenemos una combinación del teorema
fundamental del cálculo con la regla de
la cadena